la polynésie donc françois mitterrand le
chef de l'état est arrivé en polynésie
je vous disais il ya un instant qu'il
avait été sévère dans son constat des
déséquilibres frappant ce territoire
français de près de deux cent mille
habitants
ça a été l'un de ses premiers propos
antenne 2 et en polynésie
gilles leclair aimé mayol c'est surtout
demain que françois mitterrand
retrouvera la population polynésienne à
l'occasion des 100 ans de papeete en
attendant la première journée du chef de
l'état a surtout revêtu un caractère
institutionnel
personne n'a été oublié du gouvernement
local aux membres de l'assemblée
territoriale depuis 84 en effet la
polynésie jouit d'un statut d'autonomie
interne mais le premier président de la
république à s'exprimer au sein de
l'assemblée territoriale à tahiti ne
dissimule pas qu'un changement
d'institutions ne règlent pas tous
problèmes économiques chômage massif des
jeunes une dette qui s'accroît les
autorités locales doivent faire des
efforts rien ne sera durablement
construit sans l'harmonie sociale
laquelle repose il faut s'en convaincre
sur une répartition équilibrée des
fruits de la croissance françois
mitterrand a même laissé entendre qu'il
faudrait bien un jour établir sur le
territoire en impôt sur le revenu alors
qu'il n'en existe ici que sur la
consommation
ainsi dans les territoires d'outre-mer
comme en métropole le chef de l'état
plaide pour une meilleure redistribution
demain sur le terrain
il se rendra d'ailleurs encore mieux
compte des disparités économiques qui
existent ici